invaded fought over occupied retaken and
then flooded this city just never gives
up
cleanup operations in Herson continue in
the areas where the flood water has
receded
residents like Andre are clearing the
mud from their apartments and businesses
determined to start living yet again
flood waters brought filth and
potentially disease into his small shop
we have to wash it all the water was up
to the ceiling everything is covered in
filth it was impossible to get through
here until the flood waters went down
Ukraine says Russia committed a war
crime by destroying the dam that caused
these floods Russia denies
responsibility
these are the same streets now
Ukraine says 44 Villages remain flooded
17 of which are in Russian occupied
territory on the opposite side of the
river
we're in this area about a week ago and
the water level then was about a meter
deep as you can see the floods here have
receded but there are many areas closer
to the river where houses huge
residential areas are still inundated
with water and of course there is a
constant threat of potential shelling
the mammoth cleanup operation here
continues but some of the worst affected
areas are out of town
Natalia has lived on the banks of the
English River for four decades
her husband passed away in recent years
when the dam was destroyed on the danipa
river water flooded up the tributary
engulfing her land and home
the water came at first it was there
then reached up to the middle of the
garden when the water reached the
threshold then we started to run away
the floods have receded here too but the
river is still twice the width it was
before the dam was destroyed
Wells are filled with mud many villages
have no drinking water in the affected
area
here were tomatoes next I had zucchini
then there were onions beets carrots
then potatoes I had everything now there
is nothing everything is under the reeds
she shows us the flood water marks on
her house and leads us inside
lies in filthy ruins amongst the mud
soaked collapsing walls her
grandchildren's discarded toys her
wardrobe and clothes everything she
calls her own everything she loves and
treasures destroyed
she looks at a photo of her daughter and
struggles to hold back the tears she
knows that despite the help she hopes
will come rebuilding her life as the war
rages will be hard beyond words Charles
Strafford Al Jazeera her son region
Ukraine